all right we don't really do things like
this but we've got a contest that we are
running where you can actually win and I
have to be careful how I say this
because of course the lawyers are
standing right off-camera making sure
that I am completely precise on what I
say you can win tokens that you could
conceivably exchange for monetary value
right this is not a raffle it's not a
lottery or anything like that here's the
way it works
the David Pakman show as I've mentioned
before has started publishing content to
steam it steam it is a blockchain based
curation platform sort of like a reddit
type platform where rewards are earned
based on the up votes that your content
receives you can find the david pakman
show on steam it at STW MIT /at sign
david pakman here's the contest that
we're running and you have to be on
steam it in order to participate in this
contest at the top of our steam at
profile the david pakman show has right
now an avatar a round picture and it is
a picture of my face and to some people
it's a very very disturbing image very
disturbing image and the contest that
we're running is for people to design a
new avatar for the David Pakman show on
steam it which will be our avatar for a
week okay the winner which will be
chosen by the votes of the community on
steam it one vote one point the winner
will get 75 steam backed dollars these
are cryptocurrency tokens and again I'm
being very specific in the language that
I use which if you converted them into
US dollars would be worth roughly 650 US
dollars okay this is not a small amount
of steam backed dollar tokens Pat is
understanding the language that I'm
using here it's very precise language
the winner will win 75 steam back
dollars and then what you do with them
after that whether you convert them to
Bitcoin or US dollars or whatever at
whatever value they have at the time
that's your business not mine because
all we're doing is giving away some
steam back dollars so what do you do if
you want to participate well number one
you should have at least some graphic
design skills so you can put
there's something that looks good it's
got to be related to the show in some
way but the only way to enter and you
have until I believe it is Sunday or
Monday to enter you go to steam it comm
slash at David Pakman ST double e MIT
dot-com slash David Pakman check in the
posts that we have made for the one
called contest win seventy-five steam
back dollars and submit your entry as a
comment there on Monday I will choose
the top selections and create a new post
and then whichever logo or avatar gets
the most up votes will win the 75 steam
back dollars and that's basically it if
you don't have an account on Steam it
you've got to create one it can take
about a day to get the account approved
typically very very exciting we're
giving away 75 steam back dollars and I
encourage you to join me over there use
the link in the video description and
next week we will start the voting